hello everyone making a technical video
after a long time so every student of
mechanical engineering Aerospace and
civil uh would realize what these
equations are these are basically the
stress transformation equations problem
is that I cannot ever remember these so
I thought that would be a better way to
remember these than to use matrix
multiplication which is quite easy and
straightforward and very systematic to
remember
so the way that we are going to proceed
to understand this is uh and to and to
go through the derivations rather
quickly is to use symbolic python in the
Jupiter notebook platform
so first of all we are going to import
the package
import Sim Pius Sim
and then I'm going to define the symbols
required to build up the stress Matrix
so
just to keep things simple at first
I have deliberately kept things
absolutely blank to start out with so
that students can follow along
so we have this thing Sigma XX displayed
nicely and we can go ahead and display
the other things the sigma YY and the
sigma x y
foreign
that also
sorry
the underscore should not be there all
right so we have this thing and now we
can
just build up the stress Matrix like
this
I could have written these things
earlier but I wanted to demonstrate
everything live
so here we are
ok so we have this Matrix and we want to
obtain from this these Transformations
so
uh
let us Define a column Matrix like this
now please note that I have used this
Theta without first defining what Theta
Theta is and I am going to get an error
so
to Define that this is a matrix but even
so I'll get an error
so I'll have to first Define an a Theta
because by default symbolic python will
not understand what Theta is and now it
will so
I'll display this thing also
so we have this cos Theta sine Theta and
let's let's use this so
this thing transpose will look like this
just a horizontal version of that column
Matrix
uh but I want to use this
the transpose of this into the stress
Matrix
into
the same thing
and let's see what we get out of this
so we get this one element Matrix
but we can
name this and make it more systematic uh
so Sigma
x x transformed
will be this
and I can also expand this out
so what I'll do is I'll take the
okay let
take the zeroth element out of this and
then expand it out let's see if this
thing works
and the land display this also
um
sorry
there should be a bracket here
okay so this is my Sigma xx and if you
compare this expression with
this one here
you'll see that matches so Sigma X is
cos squared theta plus y Sigma X Y sine
Theta cos Theta Sigma y by sine squared
theta that's exactly the same thing here
so this seems pretty easy enough
is easy enough to remember also using
this CS Matrix and we can have similarly
the
uh the sigma X Y version of this so if I
Define it like
Sim dot matrix
Sim dot course Sim Dot
Pi by 2 plus
Theta comma same dot sine
dot Pi by 2
Plus
so I'm making a call Matrix out of theta
plus pi by 2.
and let's display this thing also
so minus sine Theta cos Theta and all
that I'll do for the
Sigma X Y transformed
is to write this as
uh so I'll just repeat the same thing
over here that I had written here
except I'll substitute the second one
with a CSA Matrix this one
let's see if this thing has worked
[Music]
so we have the exact same thing okay so
you can just compare this with the
earlier version
so Sigma X Y cos Square Theta minus sine
squared theta so we do have this Sigma X
Y cos squared theta minus sine squared
theta and then we have this minus of
Sigma XX minus Sigma y by sine Theta cos
Theta we have that term here
the first term and the last terms so
this was easy enough but I want to make
this even more systematic so
what I'll do is I'll use the rotation
Matrix for this this is slightly at a
higher level compared to undergraduate
syllabus but I think in some places they
do teach it at least here at IIT I do
teach it in my class so at least I refer
to it and this is also taught in the
first year linear algebra courses of
engineering mathematics so the rotation
Matrix will be
defined like this
so this is cos Theta
sine Theta
and the second root will be
minus
sine Theta
if I can spell correctly
and let's display this
so we have cos Theta sin Theta minus
sine Theta cos Theta I am sure it will
be familiar to quite a few students now
the way we can proceed with the stress
transformation in one shot in one line
is to do simply this so Sigma
transformed or stress transformed
um or stress Matrix ah
transformed will be equal to Q times
the
stress Matrix which we had defined
earlier
that one
stress Matrix
times Q transpose
so if we display this thing
we're going to get all these terms in
one shot so the first
row First Column is the sigma XX the
first row second column is the sigma x y
and the second row second column is the
sigma YY which by the way we had not
derived earlier uh we can make this
thing look a little bit prettier
by trying to expand
let's see if that works
so right so we have this pretty good
looking expressions and then we can
individually extract out the sigma
the sigma XX Dash is equal to stress
Matrix
transformed
0 comma 0
Sigma X Y dash is equal to
0 comma 1 and sigma YY Dash is equal to
stress Matrix transformed this thing and
then I'll just display all of them
together
oh sorry
spelling mistake
all right
so in one shot basically in these input
cell number 17 on input cell numbers 15
17 and 19 I have obtained my answers
okay so this is much easier to remember
all that I really have to remember is
how this rotation Matrix is set up cos
Theta sine Theta minus sine Theta cos
Theta and I can obtain all the
expressions in one group I don't have to
go for any kind of mental hacks to
remember these things okay and by the
way these things ah this this formula
for stress transformation it works also
in three dimensions although here I have
just ah
demonstrated for two Dimensions all
right that's it I hope you find it
useful thank you very much